hi everybody
my name is maxine chevalier bavar and
i'm a grad
student at the university of morial and
i do research in dynamic programming
languages and more specifically
dynamic programming language
optimization and today
in this talk i'm going to give you a
little bit of the history of dynamic
programming languages
with an angle towards optimization
what's been done to
to make them run fast so
donald knuch recently said i think of a
programming language
as a tool to convert a programmer's
mental images
into precise operations that a machine
can perform the main idea is to match
the user's intuition
as well as possible and this last part
resonated with me i think that dynamic
programming languages have recently
acquired a lot of popularity
and the key to understanding that is
that they match the user's intuition
better
they allow you to express your ideas at
a higher level
and to leave more things implicit and
have the machine
accomplish those things more directly
so in terms of programming i think
to understand dynamic languages we have
to go back to the beginning
so at the first digital computer the
eniac had to be programmed by flipping
a large number of switches on a panel
but it also wasn't
a truly general purpose computer it had
to be rewired
for each program that you were going to
run on this machine
and so this was extremely time consuming
and error prone
and people quickly looked for ways to
make the programming
of computers simpler and one of the
first innovations they came up with was
to apply the idea of
punch cars programming so this is a 1620
ibm assembler punch card where you you
punch holes in the card
to directly represent machine
instructions that the computer is going
to run
and so this allows you to program your
program once
and then to be able to run it many times
of course programming punch cards is
very tedious
if you want to debug them you have to
look through all of your punch cards
uh it's easy to get them out of order
and here
we have a stack of punch cards where
somebody labeled
the the [ __ ] the functions the
subroutines on top
and of course punch cards being uh paper
have to go through a punch card readers
which which is a mechanical device and
they were also prone to jamming so
destroying your your punch cards
and so people again looked for ways to
to streamline the programming process
and make it easier
and this is a quote by john backus much
of my work
has come from being lazy i didn't like
writing programs and
so when i was working on ibm 701 writing
programs for computing
missile trajectories i started to work
on a programming system
to make it easier to write programs and
this programming system was going to be
fortran which stood for formula
translating system
and from the very beginning it was
geared towards engineering
and military applications but now you
have the possibility
of of writing your program in in a text
format
and editing them on uh on a terminal and
then compiling them and doing
letting the computer do that work for
you
at the same time as people were working
on fortran
john mccarty was beginning his research
into ai
at mit and he had a mathematical
background he had a phd in mathematics
and so he wanted to have something more
symbolic his research was going to be
about common sense reasoning and
automated tier improving so he wanted a
language where
you could operate at the level of
recursive symbolic expressions
and this was going to become lisp
i think also that one of the main
driving factors was uh
platform independence he wanted
portability and this was especially
important at the time because
nowadays you know we still think of
portability is something really
important
but in the 50s they hadn't even agreed
on the 8-bit bytes
for example the the computer that the
original lisp was written for the ibm
704 had 36-bit words
so in 1960 he published this report
recursive functions of symbolic
expressions
and our copy nation by machine part one
there was never a part two
and this outlines uh the original lisp
and many of it if it's important
features
i would say that lisp had a lot of
influence on the language
that followed it it was uh the first
dynamic language and also the first
functional language and many of its
features are still found
in all dynamic languages today
features like dynamic typing so types
are associated with
with values and not with variables as in
static languages
late binding so names are resolved
dynamically when you when you call a
function the lookup
is semantically done at runtime instead
of statically resolved
the eval function saw this idea that you
can
generate new code and evaluate it
dynamically
and finally the redevelop print loop
which was enabled
by the eval function so the edit that
you can write code and test it
interactively
and this must have been revolutionary uh
in the late 50s and early 60s because
people were still at the time
programming
by punching cards so this idea you could
be in front of a computer
and write code and immediately get a
result
must have been really game changing
and finally there's also garbage
collection
lisp is a language that generates
intermediate data that operates on list
and so without garbage collection list
would have been pretty much
impossible because you would have had to
constantly be freeing up
all the closures that you allocate and
all the intermediate lists
and so garbage collection was invented
for this original
lisp now unfortunately dynamic languages
have this reputation for being
slow or at least slower than statically
typed programming languages and we
we should probably ask the question why
well it's because a lot of the
the features that make it so convenient
to use also introduce
uh some overhead and especially at the
time they didn't really know yet how to
make those things fast
so garbage collection uh was invented
for lisp so
it was really in its infancy at the time
and they used a mark sweep garbage
collector which was fairly inefficient
because
you needed to traverse all of the
objects that were allocated
in order to find out which ones were
still live
also stop the world gcs garbage
collectors that introduced
can introduce a pause when they
interrupt your program to the garbage
collection
and there were also semi-spaced gcs
copying garbage collectors that were
invented shortly after but these can
cause a huge waste of memory
because you're actually having to
reserve half of your heap
to be empty space for for the next
collection
and at the same time you actually waste
even more memory than that because
if you're you're half heap your semi
space is near full you're going to be
garbage collecting all the time so you
actually need more to
more like 4 to 7x overhead
and then there's dynamic type tests so
operators in dynamic languages
change meaning depending on what values
you're passing to them
so they perform a different operation
based on the input types
so for example the plus operator in a
language like javascript could mean
integer addition
it could also mean floating point
addition it could mean
string concatenation and in some other
languages it could also mean
array concatenation so inside each
operator you have many different
operations and many hidden
type tests that have to be performed
dynamically
so this is an example from javascript if
you have a simple function that just
does
n plus one if you do add one of two it's
going to return the integer tree
if you do add one of hello it's going to
do a string concatenation
if you do add one of true you get two if
you do add one of null you get one add
one of undefined you get another number
add one of an object with a two string
function that returns the string tree
you get 31
but tostring doesn't actually have to
return a string it could also return an
integer and then you get four
so inside of the javascript plus
operator you have to be able to handle
all of these cases
yes and then there's
property access uh in a language like
javascript
objects can grow dynamically and
properties can also be dynamically
deleted
and then you can do property enumeration
you have some introspection capability
so objects in javascript and similar
languages behave a little bit like hash
maps
where you're mapping string keys to
values
but hash maps are relatively inefficient
they're big o of one in terms of access
time but the constant is large
and they also require you to store key
value pairs but you don't want to store
keys
and values for all the properties inside
of an object you only want to store the
values ideally and then finally there's
the eval function that comes and
complicates things
so dynamic languages are not untyped
they have typing rules
so for example if i had a the plus
operator and i say say
c equals a plus b i could say that
adding an integer to an integer produces
an
integer adding a string to a string
produces string adding string
to integer produces a string and so on
so ideally i'd like to have a smart
compiler
that can do some amount of type
inference and eliminate
unnecessary type tests to make my
program run faster
but eval complicates things because it
allows you to evaluate arbitrary code at
any point
so with eval you could potentially be
redefining any function
any global variable sometimes local
variables you could be introducing new
code into your program
and this really really complicates type
inference
so one of the earliest strategies that
was found to to optimize
dynamic languages was called type
tagging
and so this is basically a heuristic
compromise
we're saying we're going to prioritize
common operations like integer and list
operations we're going to assume
that most of the operations that we do
in a language are going to be on
integers and lists and so for example if
we have 32-bit words we're going to
steal
the lowest two bits to be a type tag so
for example zero zero would mean that my
value is an integer zero one could mean
pair
and one one would mean pointer and then
what happens is that we avoid having
an extra level of indirection when we're
fetching an integer
or a pair and so we get better
performance for these operations
we get faster type tests we get less
allocations we don't have to allocate
temporary memory for
for integers where there are no integer
objects and
so we also do less memory accesses
but this is a compromise because it also
adds a little bit of overhead to uh
box and on box values inside of this
type tagged representation
now the the 1970s were dominated by mini
computers like the pdp-11
so most of the computing in universities
was done on machines like this
and these machines were relatively slow
compared to motor machines they
sometimes run
at speeds that were less than a
megahertz and had memories that were
counted in in kilobytes
up to maybe a few hundred kilobytes and
they were sometimes shared between
many users and in a sense maybe it's not
so surprising that list
lisp didn't become a dominant
programming language at the time because
the resources were so limited and people
didn't yet know how to make dynamic
languages fast
and so they they would go to to static
languages to try to get better
performance
uh better memory characteristics and so
on
but fortunately people didn't just give
up on dynamic language
dynamic languages this machine here is
the xerox
alto design at xerox park
so xerox had a lot of success with
copiers but they wanted to diversify
and they tasked their employees with
inventing uh the office of the future
the the paperless
office and this was going to happen with
computers
and so they had this big program where
they designed these machines internally
and they had their employees
use them and these machines were really
revolutionary they were all networked
with each other they had
files in print servers they had they had
a mouse
and this was happening uh in 1972 by the
way
they also had bitmap graphics and
graphical user interfaces
uh with a desktop metaphor that we're
all familiar with
and to program uh these machines the
small talk language wasn't
was invented and small talk is uh
probably uh one of the most influential
dynamic languages out there it sort of
influenced
languages like javascript and ruby and
python and so on
it was object oriented it had classes uh
and and objects um and also the
possibility of dynamically uh
growing your objects and so on and it
also had this concept
of a live image where
everything lived inside of the same
small talk system
so uh you could be programming
and your editor which you were editing
your small talk
code was itself written in small talk so
you could modify
your editor inside of the small talk
system while you were programming in
small talk and so on and you also had a
a system browser where you could browse
all the classes in the system
and modify the kernel you could really
shoot yourself in the footer if you
wanted but it was also
extremely powerful and dynamic and at
the same time
you could suspend at any time uh your
small talk image
to a disk so you can interrupt your
session and save it to a disk like this
which could be carried uh between
different workstations
so what did small talk do about the
efficiency problem
well because the entire machine was
designed by
by people inside of xerox they sort of
had access to every layer of the design
and so they were able to implement
special micro coded instructions that
were geared
to the small talk vm implementation so
they they optimized small talk
also by by conceiving specialized
instructions for the cpu
and at the same time as this small talk
research was going on
thomas knight and richard greenblatt at
mit were working
on the lisp machine and the list machine
uh had one of its major goals was to
make lists
fast so they wanted to to tailor the
hardware to the
execution of lisp and they did this by
having a tagged architecture
where each word of memory had extra tag
bits of metadata
for type tags and also for for cdr
coding for compressing
list representations and the cpu was
directly aware of those type tags so
they had specialized instructions
where the fastpass and the type test
could be executed simultaneously so
instead of
of having operations where you need to
first test the type of value and then
perform an operation
they could do things like have an ad
operator that would
do floating point addition and integer
addition
and type tests all at the same time and
then select the right answer based
on the type test they could also do
array bound checks in parallel with
array access to save time
and they also use micro coded
instructions uh to implement some lisp
parameters basically directly inside the
cpu
and to reduce call overhead sometimes to
as little as a
20 cycles and to optimize garbage
collection
interestingly the operating system was
also written in lisp
and so there were many spin-off
companies that were created by mit
students that that really uh
fell in love with those list machines so
for example this is the
the symbolics 3600 series list machines
now unfortunately this machine didn't
really survive and i think
one of the things that killed it is the
arrival of the microprocessor
and eventually of the personal computer
and maybe you could say that this is a
bit of
the rise of uh of worse is better in a
sense uh
pcs were not nearly as fast as uh
workstations like the list machine
and the xerox alto but they cost less
than a thousand dollars whereas list
machines
cost as much as 10 to 50 000
and they couldn't be mass produced they
were done with techniques like
wire wrapping and discrete logic so the
the logic inside the machine was very
much handmade by
by a lot of employees where species
could be mass produced in factories
another thing that contributed to the
debt of uh
specialized hardware and the list
machine is that people found better ways
eventually to
to make dynamic languages faster for
example neil d
jones invented a flow analysis for for
scheme which
was able to deduce types based on typing
rules for the language
and eliminates type checks and dynamic
lookups
this particular technique doesn't really
solve the problem of a valve but in
scheme they had this advantage that
eval had more restricted semantics so
you could pass it an environment to
execute in
and it couldn't touch the local
variables inside of your functions
and so uh this analysis kcfa is very
useful for scheme but a little less
applicable to to other languages
there was also more research done at
xerox spark the self-programming
language was
basically a descendant of small talk and
i started described on hacker news uh
as a smoc a small talk that was more
small talking than small talk
so it was even more dynamic basically
everything was an object even
your stack frames your local variables
inside of a
function or access through an object but
despite the fact that it was even more
dynamic than smok talk they found ways
to make it even faster
so they claimed up to half the speed of
optimized c
and this was used to several key
innovations like type feedback and
profile driven optimization so this idea
that like you can
let your program run for a while and
observe the types that actually occur
in your program and then generate better
code based on on the types that you
observed they also had inline caching to
speed up property accesses inlining of
message
sends and dynamic de-optimization
and finally maps which are really
crucial for dynamic language to optimize
object layouts
so what is the the idea of of maps well
in javascript you can create object
literals
like this and ideally you would want
to represent them as as classes but
uh the objects behave a little bit more
like hash maps so ideally you would want
to have
a class layout for your object literals
where you say
i know exactly the offset in memory of
each property so x would be like an
offset zero uh and then in my object
level b
i could say that a is that offset zero b
is at a c is at 16 and so on so
basically
you would like to be able to access your
objects as if they were c
structs and you knew exactly where each
member is located
but this is a bit problematic because in
most dynamic languages you can add
properties dynamically
which would invalidate any fixed layout
that you come up with
and you can also delete properties
dynamically
so what can we do then well the idea
behind maps is that
you can actually have multiple class
layouts for your objects
and so your objects can change class
dynamically at execution time
so you can have multiple fixed class
layouts and have the objects
change the class they belong to so this
is
like the idea of hidden classes that's
used inside of google chrome
during the 1990s we saw the rise of many
dynamic languages
uh most of them interpreted most of them
not very fast but i think we got to the
point where pcs were so fast
uh that it didn't matter so much anymore
and also maybe
in in the web world people care more
about fast prototyping than they cared
about having absolute execution speed
but there were never less projects to
optimize some of these languages
projects such as pi pi
and luagit which focused on tracing and
managed to uh to get some very good
results
in terms of performance uh more recently
uh there's been a war between mozilla
and uh
and google for the javascript
performance crown and this has been a
big driving factor
in improving the performance of dynamic
languages
so chrome has a fast baseline jit
internally so they have a jit that can
generate code that is not very optimized
but that generates code very fast to
allow it to
start executing your program very fast
and they also have the crankshaft
optimizing just in time compiler to
generate more optimized code
and internally they use a lot of the
techniques that were pioneered
for languages like self so they have
hidden classes that are a bit like
like maps for object layout and they use
inline caching
type feedback dynamic de-optimization
which allows them to
undo inlining decisions if they find out
that
those landing decisions are wrong and on
stack replacement
which allows them to replace functions
by optimized
versions at runtime
inside of firefox there's an interpreter
a baseline jit and the iron monkey
optimizing you so you have a bit of a
similar structure where the interpreter
allows them to
start executing your program very fast
what they do is they do a lazy first
pricing so
you can dump a lot of javascript code on
it but the first parsing
will actually only check for syntax
error and establish where the functions
are located inside the file
and then only the first time that you
call a function will it
generate byte code and and parse the
function
and then they use a lot of the same
techniques that were pioneered for cells
like maps inline caches type feedback
dynamic the optimization and so on but
recently they've uh
they've made an innovation and they
added an extra ingredient which is a
hybrid
type inference analysis and the reason
why this is significant
is that they finally found a way to to
solve the eval
problem so they will be able to
incrementally analyze your program
essentially and get some some type
inference results that are correct
up to the current point in execution and
then if you
you do an eval and you introduce some
new code that invalidates some of their
optimization results they will be able
to analyze that new code and reanalyze
the rest of the program and update
the types that they've inferred with
their analysis and essentially recompile
the parts of the code that are no longer
valid dynamically
and this uh this makes a tremendous
difference on benchmarks it has allowed
them to
to beat chrome on some of them
uh so where do i come in well uh
i've done my master's thesis at mcgill
university
and my advisor wanted me to work on
optimizing the matlab programming
language
and i think she was very interested in
in numerical optimization so optimizing
matrix multiplications for for example
but what i latched on was the fact that
matlab was a dynamic language
and that it would be very useful for
example to be able to do things like
type inference and infer the dimensions
of matrices and so on
and you need type information to be able
to to optimize this code
i also came to believe that dynamic
languages require dynamic compilers that
is to say
uh to successfully optimize dynamic
languages we need to be able to have a
system
that can react at runtime to the
changing states
of of the programs
and what i'm working on right now is a
javascript vm called higgs
so higgs has an interpreter and a jit
compiler for for x86 64
and has support for most of ecmascript
five so it's a it's a javascript vm
and it's a platform to try uh various
optimization ideas it's
got a relatively small code base uh so
less than fifty thousand lines of code
which makes it easy for one person to
understand the whole thing and for me to
refactor
as much of it as i need
and what i'm working on right now is an
optimization technique called
basic block versioning so this has some
similar ideas with
techniques like tracing and procedure
cloning so the fundamental idea is that
as you compile code you can
accumulate information accumulate facts
that help you to to optimize and
specialize this code
and compile multiple versions of the
code that can handle
different types uh efficiently so uh
some of the
information we can specialize based on
is things like low level type
information
uh register allocation state and also
object types and global variable types
so how does this work well uh a very
simple example here
suppose we have a loop that does a lot
of
bitwise and so each iteration it will
compute the bitwise and of
v and i and also increment uh the loop
counter i so this is actually from
the sunspider bitwise and benchmark
so to a compiler this loop will look a
little bit more like this
that is each operator is actually
sort of like a function that has some
some complex logic hidden inside
so the less than function the less than
operator is a function
call and so is the ad and so is the
bitwise and
and inside an operator like bitwise and
typically what's going to be done is
that we're going to check the type of
of the inputs x and y and then we'll
have a fast path here that will use
an optimized machine instruction that
does bitwise and
only in integers and if x and y are not
integers we're going to have a slope at
where we
we sort of do the the general purpose
operation so we're going to convert
x and y to integers and then do uh a
general
a bitwise n on that
same thing goes for for the add
operation typically we'll we'll do a
type test and we'll have a fast path
and then if x and y are not actually
integers we're going to handle
the case for for strings and all the
other types elsewhere
there's an extra complication in that
add
will have to do an overflow check it'll
have to check that the results of the ad
actually fits in a 32-bit integer and if
it doesn't
it will have to uh convert x and y to
double values and do the operation on on
a double instead
and similarly for uh
for less than we're also going to have a
fast and slow path
and so putting it all together the loop
is going to be transformed into
something a little more like like this
so each operator is going to have a fast
path and a slow pad
so now this introduces a bunch of of
type tests into a loop
and to make our program run fast we
would like to eliminate them
so the first thing that's pretty obvious
is that testing the type of constant is
not necessary so we know that those
values
600 000 and 1 are integers so we can
immediately eliminate those type tests
so this leaves us with
the following so how do we eliminate
those
well with basic block versioning i'm
going to make the assumption
that when i enter the loop i is an int
32 value so i know this from here
and so i can eliminate this first type
test because i know that when i enter
the loop
i is going to be integer
and then the same thing goes for v it's
also integer when i enter the loop so i
can eliminate those two type tests as
well
and also the last one and so i'm going
to be left
with only this code here and what i see
is that when i perform the bitwise and
here
on those two integer values i will also
get an integer as output
and when i do the add of i plus 1 i also
get an integer here
so the next time i'm going to go around
the loop i'm going to have
integer values uh going in as well
unfortunately this is maybe a little
further complicated by the overflow so
if i wasn't in a case
where i get an integer overflow i would
be converting my values to
my value i to a double and getting a
double result back
so this is a bit of a problem because i
i've assumed here
that those values were integer when i
entered a loop
so what i can do with basic block
versioning is say that
if i get a double result i'm going to
generate a new loop version that assumes
instead
that i is a double and i'm going to jump
to that loop version that handles that
case separately so i can keep
this loop here optimized and have
another version elsewhere that's going
to handle other type combinations
so this is a bit of a multi-world
approach so in a traditional type
analysis i'm going to do
what's called a fixed point on types
which means that at any program point i
must have
a solution that agrees with all the
inputs and so i must get a pessimistic
or conservative answer so if i don't
know
that a value i is an integer and i have
that it must be integer
or float or integer or double then maybe
i have to compromise and say i don't
know where the type is
but with basic block versioning i can
say i can have multiple solutions
possible
and i can have multiple versions of code
that handle different combinations of
types
so we don't necessarily have to
sacrifice performance so basically this
is shifting
uh the fixed points to the versioning of
of code blocks instead of doing it for
a fixed point on the types so there's a
lot of interesting research questions
about this
like how much code blow up we can expect
and what kind of performance gains
and what's the effect of compilation
time so i've already implemented
a simple version of basic block
versioning inside of higgs and i can say
that the
the answers to this so far are pretty
encouraging there isn't much code blow
up
it doesn't slow compilation time by a
lot and it does reduce the number of
type tests
significantly
so for the last part of this
presentation i'd like to speculate a
little bit about
about the future the future of dynamic
languages that is
so speculating about the future is maybe
a little risky
uh people have been notoriously wrong
but i think that if we look if we look
at the past and the present and current
trends
and maybe we extrapolate those trends
only a little bit into the future we can
probably make
some good educated guesses
so what does the future hold well i
think there's at least three things that
are going to change in terms of dynamic
language
optimizations three aspects um
i think we're going to get more advanced
smarter cpu so this is probably pretty
obvious but uh
like cpus like the intel uh i7
are very very advanced now they do
register rewriting behind the scenes
they had
huge multi-level caches they have the
ability to dispatch and execute multiple
instructions per clock cycle they do
branch prediction they do a lot of
things behind the scenes that you don't
see
i think that probably intel is going to
throw even more silicon at the problem
and maybe we're going to see cpus that
can actually execute multiple branches
in parallel speculatively for example
we're also going to get more
instructions per cycle and so on
and it's going to get to the point where
despite the fact that we don't have uh
hardware that's specialized for dynamic
languages we're going to get sort of
the same results maybe eventually we'll
be able to run our type tests
and our typed operations simultaneously
inside of the cpu
i also happen to know that intel is
speaking with people at mozilla
about new instructions that will be
specifically made for optimizing dynamic
languages so those might come
in the next few years i think we're also
going to get smarter compilers
so people don't like hearing about
sufficiently smart compilers
but compilers are in fact getting
smarter there are new techniques that
are being devised for optimizing dynamic
languages
and there's also a lot of techniques
that have been invented in academia that
are not in use
just yet that haven't really made it but
that will probably make it into uh
into modern dynamic language compilers
in the next few years so we're going to
get better optimizations
and also maybe better language design so
what do i mean by better language design
well
i think it's important to remember that
javascript
is a language that was designed in all
of two weeks by brandon ike when he was
working at netscape
so when he designed javascript he didn't
really have performance in mind
he wanted to have a language to write
glue code to fit on top of html
and so many of the features of
javascript
make me as a compiler writer want to
pull my hair out
but if we had dynamic languages that
were designed more with performance in
mind
maybe we could actually do a better job
at optimizing them
and finally in terms of the future of
dynamic languages i think that
there's a number of uh good ideas coming
from other languages that have caught on
so
from lisp for example we got dynamic
typing
we have closures now if your language
doesn't have closures
people don't take it seriously it's
become
you know everybody's become convinced
that closures and and the rebel for
example
are good features to have from the
haskell ml world we're starting to see
type inference make it into dynamic
languages except that
type inferences in dynamic language is
going to be transparent it's going to be
happening behind the scenes
from small talk we're seeing that
prototypal inheritance and duct typing
has become you know relatively
mainstream in in javascript for example
i think that there are more more good
ideas from those languages that maybe
will eventually become mainstream
so from from list the ideas of a macros
and domain
specific languages will maybe become
eventually mainstream
maybe also the idea of ast manipulation
so code is data
in lisp you could actually generate asds
directly
you can't really do that in motor
languages but maybe we'll get languages
eventually that can look at their own
ast
and modify them and implement a macro
system and function of that
i also think that ideas like pattern
matching and
non-nullable types from haskell will
eventually propagate because they're
actually
really good ideas and maybe also a focus
on consonants purity and immutability
this becoming
increasingly important with multi-core
and distributed programming
and finally from small talk and self uh
the idea of live programming the idea
that uh
you can uh perform microsurgery and
running system maybe it's going to
become more relevant now that we have so
many distributed systems
and that uptime is so critical maybe in
the future we won't
have systems that we interrupt and
restart all the time but instead we'll
have systems that
that just run forever and also with your
level of of non-volatile ram
maybe having persistent systems is going
to become more mainstream
so this is it for my presentation thank
you